okay
so what happened um last time so we
talked about
the workhorse model of
of you know classical or classical
economics in terms of discounted the
exponential
uh discounted utility model
this is a very useful model for many
settings
it's been very useful for explain and
understand a bunch of behaviors
however this model has a few assumptions
that create sort of some predictions
that are not necessarily borne out in
the data
and we're trying to sort of improve on
those assumptions and make the model
more realistic what are these
assumptions so what kinds of examples
did i show you that perhaps were not
consistent with the uh
exponential discounting model
i'll actually show them to you but can
somebody explain to you what they are
and why
why are those not uh consistent with the
exponential discounting model
yes uh you should it shouldn't determine
if you shouldn't care about whether it's
day to day tomorrow and then here
so one uh key assumption in the
exponential discounting model is that
there's one parameter delta
that uh that essentially uh steers
how much you care about different
periods of time
the present and the future or to future
periods
the key assumption here is that how much
weight do you put on different time
periods an earlier and a later date is
constant across time
so from today versus tomorrow there's
the same difference
compared to like when you look at like a
year from now and a year and a day from
now
or like 20 days and 21 days the
difference you should if you care more
about the present
that's constant across time from the
today's perspective also from future
perspective
that's one assumption and now what
evidence did we see or show that
uh uh that that's not consistent with
uh like choosing a reward you want the
money now versus today
right so we saw some evidence that
people are uh impatient in the short run
so when it comes to today versus
tomorrow or today versus in a week from
now people tend to be fairly impatient
they tend to discount the future a lot
now there's sort of two issues with that
one is if you do the same thing about
asking people about future rewards
people tend to be more patient so like
the discount factors that you elicit
we'll talk a little bit about that in
this recitation as well the discount
factors are just different for
the same uh intervals of time
second if you take the short run in
patients seriously if you sort of say
okay i take your choices from today
versus tomorrow from the day versus next
week
ensure that does run not forward you've
got sort of absurd implications and then
like if you really seriously discount
like a week from now
by a lot that well then you shouldn't
care about like a year from now five
years from now
you shouldn't care about that at all
however we see in the real world
people have lots of people care about
the future a lot people save money
people um
get education and so on and so forth so
it can't be in some ways that
they're really impatient in the long run
as well
so that's like number one um what about
point number two
yes uh your decision
now for the future should be the same as
once you actually do that
no new information comes about but
people know
exactly that's called dynamic or time uh
consistency
that's a an assumption or implication of
the exponential discounting
model that is to say if i make some
choices for the future for future
periods
about how i um uh uh whether i'm going
to study next week or in a year from now
or whether i'm going to exercise and so
on
for choices that involve sort of time in
the future
once that time comes absent new
information or absence
circumstances change i should follow
through with my plans
and so if that's not the case then what
we say is uh then preferences
are dynamically inconsistent that is to
say i have all sorts of plans of
exercising
um uh next week and so on the next
becomes surprise i'm not following
through
that essentially it means my preferences
are inconsistent and that sort of
evidence against the exponential
discounting model okay
number three demand for commitment yes
um
right so one uh sort of key assumption
or one sort of like
uh key insight from sort of economics in
general classical economics it's like
more choices are good like if you have
like more options available that's great
for you because you can take advantage
of them
you never know whether there's going to
be uncertainty or certain circumstances
change
so you should never restrict your
choices because you never know maybe in
the future
maybe circumstances change maybe i'll
get really busy or whatever
things happen so more choice tends to be
good so in the neoclassical or classical
economics model there's no
uh scope for and no reason to restrict
your choices
because you know more choices in the
future are always good
however if you're worried about your
future self misbehaving in certain ways
if you're worried about your future self
not exercising eating too many potato
chips and so on and so forth
you might want to engage in commitment
devices either by taking away certain
options just
like restricting your choice set to like
a smaller choice set
or less drastically making future
choices more expensive
that is to say for example if i say i'm
going to submit a write a paper by the
end of this week
if i'm going to tell you if i don't do
that i'm gonna give you a hundred
dollars
well um uh what i'm gonna do essentially
is i'm uh making
not writing the paper more expensive
right and the new classical
the classical model has had the
exponential discounting model has
essentially no scope for that why would
i ever do that
because who knows maybe i'll get sick or
like stuff happens
so there's no reason to do that there's
no benefit of doing that at some
potential costs
so if i see myself or somebody else
restricting their choices
that's a violation of the exponential
discounting
model and the reason of course for that
is is number two
we know there's like preference or if
you think there are future preference
reversals
if i think that in the future i might
change my preferences in a way that i
don't like
if i want my future self to behave in
certain ways that i prefer
right now i might want to restrict my
choices or i might certain unpreferable
like
less preferable options uh more costly
okay good so then what we did
the next is to say okay now um so i
showed you a bunch of evidence of that
and then what we did is then we uh sort
of presented
a slight deviation from the exponential
discounting model which is the
quasi-hyperbotic discounting model
that model is in some sense very similar
to the exponential discounting model
that i showed you
except for some small difference there's
an additional parameter that's called
beta
what does this beta do it's like a
short-term discount factor
that essentially guides all discounting
or or determines all discounting
between the present period right now
versus anything that's in the future
one broad question is like what are the
time periods is it like daily is it
yearly is it monthly or whatever
there's actually quite a bit of research
on this that people try to figure this
out
usually we think the beta the time
horizon of the beta is actually just a
few days even just a few hours
okay so for our purposes we can say it's
like daily or today
and anything that you'll see in the
problem sets and so on it needs to be
always defined but think of beta
essentially
anything that's like today or in the
next couple of days uh
anything uh uh outside of that scope is
essentially outside of
the scope of beta and sort of in the
future
now what does this beta do well it helps
us to separate
um discounting for shorter rise and long
horizons
because you think about like discounting
between the present
and anything in the future the data can
sort of um steer that right if beta is
like 0.7.6 or 0.8 or whatever
um i can now be impatient for the
present i can now prefer say 10
today versus 12 in the future the beta
will make sure that that happens
but when you look at all future periods
the beta is in all future periods right
it appears like everywhere in the
utility function in all future periods
so the beta does not affect how how am i
discounting any future time periods
so then uh the delta is steering that
we usually think that delta is close to
one it's something like yearly
not 0.95 or 0.99 or the like so delta is
like
essentially reasonably close to 1 such
that um
i can be fairly patient between like 10
years from now and 11 years from now
in 15 years from now uh it doesn't
matter much to me there's going to be
slight
some slight discounting i prefer
probably things that are happening five
years from now
from things that are happening uh 30
years ago from now
for the same sort of stuff happening but
you know people tend to be fairly
patient do you have any questions about
that
okay so let me now sort of um
spend in fact the rest of the lecture
just talking about details of this model
in part sort of building intuition sort
of showing you the mechanics of how that
works and how essentially uh
having an additional discount parameter
the beta affects people's choices
and second we're going to talk about
something that's quite important which
is the question of sophistication versus
naivete
what do i mean by that well in the
exponential discounting model
by assumption uh preferences are time
consistent what does that mean
if i make plans for the future i will
follow through with those plans
so in some sense it doesn't really
matter what i think i'm going to do in
the future because essentially i'm going
to do anyway what i'm going to plan
anyway
so the only thing i need to know is like
right now what i'm going to do
and then if i make that plan unless
circumstances change i'm going to just
follow through
that's not true here anymore as i'm
going to show you so now it's the case
that if i make some plans right now
these plans might change in the future
because of my preferences
like even in the absence of new
information or new circumstances
once tomorrow comes or next week comes i
might sort of
prefer different things so like now the
preference are not
dynamically consistent anymore so what i
prefer today
might not be what i prefer uh next week
so that now leads to a complication now
i need to understand
well what i what are my beliefs about
what i'm going to do in the future is
quite important do we have correct
beliefs do i understand that i'm present
biased do i understand that in the
future i might be impatient as well
or am i naive do i think like right now
i'm present biased but tomorrow comes so
next week i'm going to exercise
do the problem set early and so on and
so forth and as we're going to see that
will lead to quite
um different stark uh strictly different
conclusions or implications that are
quite important for
outcomes welfare and so on okay
so let me give you sort of some examples
um first
so first if you have a discount function
function for
beta equals one half and delta close to
1. for our purposes often i'm going to
set delta to 1
not because i necessarily think that
delta is is 1 delta is probably 0.99
0.95 or the like i'm just setting it to
1 to make the algebra
or like sort of any problem set
exercises and so on
um uh being less messy uh speaking of
which problems that exercise is pure
look who sits in the very back and
checks whether you are using a laptop
only for
uh classwork um luke is sort of mostly
in charge of doing the problem sets
so he also has office hours to which you
can come and ask specific questions
about the problem sets of course he's
also very happy to answer questions
about um
on piazza or or in any other way
when are your office hours
1 30 on friday and where are they
perfect so it's on the course website um
so if you have specific questions about
the problem set
again in the recitation uh i will
discuss quite a few issues related to
that but then if you have specific
questions about the problem set um
public will be the best equipped to
answer those
okay so if you have a quasi-hyperbolic
discounting preferences with beta equals
one-half and delta
equals one your discounting function
looks essentially as follows
the first period is sort of normalized
to one we i care like one
uh about the current period in the
future then it's like beta delta beta
delta square
beta delta to the power of 3 and so on
but if you sort of
now use delta equal one you get
essentially you care about the present
one and everything in the future is
discounted by
one half okay so relative to the present
period all future periods are worth less
so i care a lot about the present that's
why we call it sort of present bias or
present focus
i care a lot more about the present than
anything in the future
now second all discounting in this
specific example takes place between the
present and the immediate future
so i only care about in terms of
discounting all future periods are the
same for me i don't care about whether
things are in five periods or six or
seven periods from now
that's all the same for me but because
delta in this case is one
uh instead what i care about is that
today versus tomorrow or today versus
three days from now
um and so on again usually delta would
not be one so if you had a delta that's
like 0.99 or the like
there would be some discounting in the
future as well
but not in this case so that's sort of
capturing the intuition that the long
run
um in the long run we are relatively
patient right there's essentially no
discounting happening anymore
um and um so the utils a year from now
are just as valuable as utos in uh
two years from now so then that also
means that the timing of decisions or
like the decisions are sensitive to the
timing of costs and benefits
when exactly they occur it matters a lot
whether stuff happens today versus
tomorrow
or you know today versus three days from
now it matters much less
about whether stuff happens in three
days versus four days from now i'm going
to show you some examples of that
but just to sort of give you some sense
of like why is this called
quasi-hyperbolic or hyperbolic
discounting
so have your three functions i'm not
sure how well you can see this but
there's like a sort of pink line that's
essentially like an exponential
uh uh uh curve that's essentially what
exponential discounting looks like
essentially what you see is like sort of
a constant if you want sort of a
decline of like um the discount function
and then i've also plotted to you like
uh uh a hyperbolic discounting which is
essentially like a true hyperbolic curve
that's essentially the thing that you
see like on the on the
on the left um uh the one that sort of
like
uh much steeper at the beginning and
then there's like quasi-hyperbolic
discounting
that's essentially quite similar in
shape as you can see to the hyperbolic
discounting
except for the fact that it's not
continuous right there's a jump um
from like going one to beta at the very
beginning it's not a continuous
function essentially there's a discrete
jump between today uh and the future
and then essentially it behaves very
similarly to the exponential discounting
curve but that's just to tell you it
doesn't really uh you don't have to
worry about the hyperbolic discounting
and so on we're not going to sort of
um discuss that very much but that's
just for you to sort of understand why
is that
why is that the name well it's because
essentially it's quasi-hyperbolic it's
not really hyperbolic because it's not
really in a hyper hyperbola
but in fact it looks quite similar
effectively
okay so then um
uh when you think about like um
goods that you might consume there's
different types of goods there's leisure
goods and there's investment goods let's
sort of start with leisure goods what's
a leisure good
a leisure good is a good that has
immediate rewards and delayed costs
one example would be eating candy so
eating candy of course you get immediate
utility benefits it's pleasurable to eat
candy
so that's positive in this case suppose
like the
uh the benefits are too um the pleasure
of eating candy right now
but often uh in you know eating candy it
leads to
delayed health costs or the date costs
at the dentist's office
which you can summarize as like see
health
of three in the future if you now say
well
if beta equals one and a delta equals
one
um well you can sort of think about like
would you eat candy
today or uh candy in the future it's
first starting off with like eating
candy today
well if you sort of calculate the costs
and benefits of feeding candy
the pleasure that you get from candy is
like two
if you uh discount the future by a beta
essentially everything in the future is
discounted by beta
it's like a one-half times three so if
you sort of do that calculation you get
something positive
so if you think about eating candy right
now the answer is yes because two minus
one half times three is positive and
you're going to do that
if instead you think about should i eat
candy in the future well you get
different
implications the answer is no why is the
answer no because
if you're in the future everything is
discounted that's happening in the
future
both the pleasure that comes from eating
candy next week but also the delayed
costs
are essentially discounted by beta so
then you essentially just have like one
half this is the beta for everything in
the future
times two which are the benefits minus
three which are the costs and that's
like smaller than
uh uh a zero so you're not going to do
that
right and that's sort of a general
feature for leisure good as we call them
these have immediate rewards and delayed
benefits
um and so what you tend to do is you
tend to over consume them
in the present relative to long run
plants
yeah so yeah you can think of this as
like um a shorthand form of saying like
um uh for example suppose you eat a lot
of candy or like
and one day you eat candy and suppose
you know these are repeated choices but
i'm sort of aggregating it into one
um you'll have essentially health costs
in the future suppose you get like
dental pain in the future
each period you have like dental pain
starting at age uh
30 or 40 50. now um uh you can sort of
think of this as like
each day you're going to have negative
utility what i'm doing now is i'm sort
of collapsing that into one day
in the sense of just making sure that uh
to make it sort of tractable
so you can think of like the late health
costs as like a summary of the health
costs overall
instead you could also write down like
0.1 uh for
your 40.1 for your 41 and so on and so
forth and sort of aggregating in that
way
but that's just for simplicity uh here
similarly you could also say like you
know
uh each day you'll have essentially a
choice to eat candy and these things
sort of add up
and again sort of simplifying in a sense
of saying like should i eat candy
uh overall which is like a number of
different choices that each are like
between the present and the future
that's just like uh changing the units
in some way overall i think the
structure of the problem is the same
yeah like obviously
i i don't know like the one kind of like
computer problem that i see with this is
like
your health is kind of the sum of like a
bunch of
actions that like you did over your
lifetime affect your health versus like
candy is like something that you know
like the
pleasure that you get out of candy is
like exactly like only depends on the
candy itself
so when people like when you do this
kind of time discounting
and you're trying to compare like health
and future like
pleasure now the fact that like the
candy contributes like
such a small amount to your like overall
like it seems kind of like an apple
store
um yeah to some degree i think that's
right i think it's in some sense that's
just an example so i could show you many
different things that are sort of
similar in structure
i'm using candy just to make it concrete
uh you could do the same with like you
know
problem sets and other pain or like
exercising and so on and so forth
um i think at the end of the day i think
that's exactly right for a lot of
choices that people make
be it like brushing their teeth be it
like uh exercising be it
um eating healthily and so on often the
costs are like the benefits are very
salient and the present are very salient
concrete
right now you have a cookie in front of
you you can eat it you'll be happy and
that's for sure
uh sometime in like 20 years from now
you might be sort of like get unhealthy
you might get like dental problems and
so on and so forth
not only is it sort of very far away but
it's also very
diffuse it's also maybe like unlikely
like you know there's a chance of
getting a heart attack at age like 70
maybe maybe not maybe you'll be just
fine so it's more complicated in a lot
of health decisions so there's other
research saying like well partially it's
about uncertainty
partially it's about the future being
like diffused and very sort of like
unclear um one part of that people tend
to think is time preferences but i think
what you're saying is like the world is
more complicated than that and that's
for sure true
um what i'm sort of saying is like
thinking about time preferences can help
you understand some choices that people
make over time
uh having said that there's lots of
other aspects here which we're sort of
grossly simplifying
but i think the key part here i think
what's really important for a lot of
health choices
tends to be that people uh that exactly
as you say
there's a lot a lot of like thousands of
like really small choices that sort of
add up to something like what's we call
it unhealthy behavior in some way
and you know each of them are like
concrete in some sense in terms of the
costs and benefits like
brushing your teeth is like costly in
some sense for five minutes or whatever
uh you know eating candy is like happy
for
a few minutes as well very concretely
and then the costs are often diffused in
the future and so on that's truly
important
we're going to talk a little bit about
this but we sort of for now at least
abstracting uh uh essentially that way
yes
[Music]
so the exponential model would not
predict you this type of behavior
right so if i if you think about like
you know you we get to this like if you
sort of say you want to make choices for
the future
the exponential discounter would give
you the same choices for the future
versus um uh what actually when the
future arrives
so i'm going to show you sort of more in
a context of problem set i'm going to
show you
there's behavior that the exponential
model cannot
just not um explain like the exponential
discounter would say either i like candy
and i
don't care about the or i just don't
worry that much about the health cost
then i eat candy
or i don't i'm really worried about the
health costs and therefore i don't need
candy
and that choice is the same today versus
next week which is two weeks from now
and so on and so forth
so once i make a choice for like eating
candy so here notice that the person who
will make
the plans to eat not eat candy in the
future
once the future arise that person will
change their um uh
uh their choice and then actually
surprise themselves potentially by
eating candy
those are just behaviors in the world
that the exponential discounting model
cannot explain
that is one of them
so there's um yeah so i think there's a
question on like what other models can
explain this
i think the hyperbolic model is in fact
quite similar as i sort of showed you in
the in the curve here you sort of see
the discount
functions are quite similar um there's a
you know there's research using the
hyperbolic model
in economics uh in the last order when
behavioral economics in the last
something like 20 years
the quasar hypomotic bulk model is the
model that everybody uses partially for
tractability and simplicity
for no uh uh uh other good reasons in
many uh settings
but in some sense what we care about and
sometimes i don't care actually that
much about like which model
among sort of a class of model that are
quite similar can explain things sort of
um uh you know if two models explain the
same thing in similar ways
i don't care about which one we should
use in a sense a simpler model is sort
of easier to use and that's why we sort
of do it
um what i care about is like there are
some predictions from the exponential
model that are sort of just not
not that they're just false and those we
need to sort of improve on
that could be either through like a a
hyperbolic model or a quasi-hyperbolic
model
to keep things simple i'm using the
quasi-hyperbolic model
in part because it nests very simply in
the exponential model
and the reason why a lot of economists
have used it is to say okay here's an
exponential model we know how to use
that model
now we're going to add one parameter and
things look very similar
and beta equals one essentially
collapses that model back to the
exponential model
and therefore people have used it and
that's essentially what we do
okay so now um uh the flip side of those
kinds of choices
are investment goods investment goods
are essentially very similar these are
goods that have immediate costs but
delayed benefits
an example would be go to the gym like
you're going to go to the gym right now
like some people you know find that fun
but many people also find it costly
there's some effort costs of say in this
case two there's benefits
health benefits of three again that's
really sort of like a stark example but
i'm just trying to make sort of a point
to make this simple
now again if we have beta equals
one-half and delta equals one
if you think about should you go to the
gym today the answer is
no and the reason is that you put a lot
of weight on the present you put like
sort of
weight of one on the present the cost of
like minus one
uh uh sorry uh you put a weight of one
on the cost of minus two so you have
minus two costs
uh the benefits are in the future you
discount them by betas you have like one
half times three
which is smaller than the zero now if
you think about then are you planning to
go to the gym next week the answer is
yes
why is that well now you're essentially
discounting everything that's in the
future
including um the cost of going to the
gym so you think about should you go to
the gym next week the answer will be yes
um the reason is because the
the health benefits overall are larger
than the costs
now again what we're gonna see then is
like uh
uh people deviate from their long-run
plans now they're under consume
investment goods relative to long-run
plans
right so we saw previously that people
over consume leisure goods they do too
much like fun stuff that has bad
consequences in the future
and people tend to do too little of like
tedious stuff that will you know yield
benefits in the future
relative to their long run um plans
again um you will get sort of
time and consistency in the sense of
like if i plan to go to the gym next
week i'm going to say yes
now if on things and unless things
change once next week arrives i'm going
to be at the choice like should i go to
the gym today
i'm going to say no i would like to not
do that
because now i'm essentially discounting
the future but not the present
any questions on that yes
one more time why you discount
the efforts as in the future
and others right
so um think of these like different
periods so the effort so if you think
about should you go to
the the costs are today
um think about these different periods
period like right now
health benefits are like say a week
later okay
so in the choice about doing it today
the costs are right now that's the
present period
so if you go back to like the discount
function you put like a weight of one on
anything that's in the present and
anything that's in the future future
period you put in a weight of one half
exactly so the effort right now is like
in the present so for
like so start with the choice of like
today the effort is in the present
that's why i'm not sort of discounting
that and the first choice for today
but if i think about doing it next week
then next week is also in the future i'm
discounting everything that's in the
future whether it's like a week
away or two weeks ago i don't care and
therefore everything is discounted by
one half okay so now
um one important distinction now is like
demand for commitment or is there
commitment available
so what we're going to do is think about
like students who have to do
problem sets uh with like very simple
beta delta
preferences so consider a student with
beta equals one-half delta equals one
there's three um periods instead of
getting pretty close to what you're
going to do in the problem so it's
actually yourself
um there's three periods you have to do
the problem set in exactly one of three
periods that's of course contrived and a
little stylized but like
uh that's just an example um for now so
there's periods t
equals zero t equals one t equals two
they're instantaneous utilities of minus
one
three halves and five halves so the
problems that becomes uh more and more
painful the later you actually
uh do it okay and uh there's only one
day in which you can actually uh do it
so now the first thing we're going to
think about is suppose there's
commitment available what does that mean
suppose the student can essentially just
pick when is she going to do the problem
set
and actually stick to that suppose they
could just sort of dictate what she's
going to do in the future
what would she choose well um
and then she actually has to sort of
stick with that so now we can sort of
think about from the perspective of
period zero remember the person is like
a
a hyperbolic discounter with beta equals
one half
um from the perspective of right now i'm
gonna say well
um the discounted utility today is like
minus one there's no discounting
happening for today if i do it today
for tomorrow i'm going to discount the
future by one half so i'm going to get
like minus three quarters
and in a period two and two days from
now i'm going to do one half
minus times minus five halves which is
uh five quarters
so if i could uh sort of predict if i
could sort of like say what i would like
to do
um i would say well um i'm going to do
it in period t equals one i'm going to
do it
tomorrow and if i could follow through
with that
is that clear
okay so now um so that's if commitment
is available what that is if i could
like essentially just force myself to do
stuff in the future and not deviate from
that
at all now if no commitment is available
how does that thinking change
yes yes exactly once t
equals one uh arrives um i might
actually
prefer not to do it in t equals one but
rather say i'd rather do it in
uh uh t equals two right and this is
exactly what you're gonna see here
this is the exact same problem uh that i
showed you before now suppose the
student has no access to the commitment
technology it's just to say
uh what if the student can just choose
in every period what is she gonna do
would she actually do it in period one
well if period one arrives
um if the the problem set is not done
if she does it at period one from the
perspective of period one
the discounted costs are minus three
halves right that's just like because
that's in the current period from the
perspective of period one
if she instead sort of were to do it in
period two she now discounts again like
period two from the perspective of
period one by one half
so one half times uh minus five halves
is five quarters
well um uh five quarters is less bad
than like uh
uh three halves so she's gonna say um
i'm gonna do it in period
two so that's to say the students uh
preferences are dynamically
inconsistent again that's sort of
something that the exponential
discounting model would not predict or
not cannot explain
and the quasi-hyperbolic model is sort
of one way of simply
creating such time inconsistency yes
we should think about the fact that for
example you know that you're going to
experience
the disability on the second period
so shouldn't your second period utility
function be the one that matters
shouldn't you as a sophisticated
period one know that you're going to
spirit minus three tasks
that is worse than what you're expecting
to experience now i don't know if i
misplaced
right this kind of like function should
be
the one that matters when you experience
the distribution right so you're sort of
saying and sometimes if i understood
right is to say and
let's see whether that's true um you're
saying like well if no commitment
is available i should never let it get
get to that point right if i'm in period
zero i should know
i'm not gonna do it actually in period
one therefore i'd rather do it right now
to avoid that all sort of like
procrastinated from period one to period
two
and if i'm now in period zero i might
say i do it rather right now because
otherwise you know i'm gonna just do it
in period two
and from the perspective of period zero
i'd rather do it right now compared to
period two
i prefer to do it in period one but
that's not feasible because my period
one self
will not uh behave in the absence of
commitment
why would you want to commit your
periods oneself
like your other self to receive bodies
because you have a different utility
function in that period so if you force
yourself to
do something on field one it's similar
so
it's just a it's just a i mean something
that's an assumption in the sense of
like
from the perspective of period zero you
make certain choices right you're gonna
say
i could do it right now i could do it in
period one or i could do it in period
two
now you have certain preferences and
you're saying maybe your preferences
should be different and that's
obviously fine i sort of specified the
preferences for the
student i said their beta is one half so
she cares about one half about anything
that happens in the future in period one
and two compared to period zero
and then sort of just sort of like
you just look at what the utilities are
and it sort of turns out that like from
her perspective from period zero
she prefers period one now you could
sort of specify the utility function
differently
um but for that specific example i guess
that's what sort of uh
uh the algebra the the the tells us
yeah okay so now
the key question now is to say okay now
the preferences are dynamically
consistent inconsistent so now what i
said well what's really important now
and in some sense maybe you're asking
about that
as well is well uh it's the question on
like
is the student aware of this time of
consistency right so you could say well
in when deciding in period zero you
might sort of say well i'd like to do it
in period one
if i believe that in period one i'm time
consistent or like if i believe that i'm
an
exponential discount or in the future i
will be very virtuous in the future
well then i'm very happy to wait until
period one and then i'm going to follow
through with my plans
if instead i know that in period one i'm
going to be present bias
well then what's going to happen is then
i can't trust myself in period one to
actually do it i know i'm gonna
procrastinate further until period two
so i'd rather do it in period zero uh to
avoid um uh sort of having to deal with
it in period uh two
let me sort of walk you through that so
i guess um we need sort of an additional
parameter to start with which is called
beta hat
okay but a hat is essentially the
sophistication on ivta parameter
beta hat is your belief about what you
think your beta will be in the future
okay so beta is like what the actual
beta is like that's the true value of
beta
in the present and in the future and
beta hat is like what you think your
beta is in the future
okay what do you believe your true or
your beta is uh uh
uh going forward it's not what you
believe you know your beta today you
know that essentially your present bias
today
everybody understands that well that's
an assumption as well and then what
people do not know or may not know what
their beta is
in the future and that's what the
parameter of beta hat
we're going to have three cases i'm
going to talk about two cases
today there's going to be a third case
starting on tuesday
and so the two cases that we are
discussing is for naivete that's to say
my beta hat equals one
that's to say i think essentially i know
i'm present biased today but i think i'm
an expensive exponential discount
discounter in the future okay so that's
to say i know i have like cell phone
control problems right now
but next week surely will be different
like you know this is like at the
beginning of the semester you know
you're kind of like screwed up in the
past
but this semester will be very different
uh you'll be virtuous and so on
that happens kind of every semester um
uh
so that's beta hat equals one uh so the
person does not realize that she will
change her mind she thinks that she's
going to follow through with her plan
her plan is to do it and t equals one
she thinks she's gonna follow through
there will be surprises about present
bias because you know you think you're
gonna do it in period one period one
arrives and surprise
uh she's present bias she mis-estimated
what she's gonna do
and then ends up sort of not doing it
and has to do it then in period
two this is sort of like false optimism
if you want about future plans
and sort of the attitude of this time is
different you know from tomorrow onwards
things will be very different we'll be
all virtuous in the future
okay and then the second part is sort of
like uh call it like perfect
sophistication that's beta hat equals
beta
that is essentially rational expectation
in a sense this is a person who
perfectly understands their preferences
i know i've seen this movie before i
know tomorrow i'm going to
procrastinate or like i'm going to be
present bias i perfectly understand what
i'm going to do
and therefore i take into account that
when making choices right now
okay and so she understands perfectly
that she will change her mind so she
understands that
she has plans to do it in period one but
you understand that the period one self
has
different preferences the period oneself
prefers to do it in period two
rather than in period one so she's kind
of like in some sense
uh uh sort of uh correctly uh
pessimistic about her future self
and sort of then uh in the case of like
these kinds of investment goods
that's a good thing because she doesn't
sort of leave stuff out she doesn't
delay things a lot for the future
she doesn't let things get bad because
she knows if if she prefer
procrastinates further she'd rather do
it right now anticipating that the
future self will not
uh follow through and here in the
perfect sophistication case
um there will be no surprises uh uh the
person always follows through with their
plans
the third case i'm going to talk about
next week is like when beta hat equals
uh
is between beta and one which is we call
like a partial sophistication or partial
uh naivete things a little more
complicated but in fact
um quite similar i think there was a
question yeah
[Music]
so but you would not sort of so you
wouldn't really carry so if you change
your minds in the future you would not
carry through with your
plans
so so either she will change your mind
in the future or not
right so if she doesn't change your mind
in the future there's no problem because
then there is no nothing to be aware of
that's kind of like the
case of the exponential discounter so if
beta hat sorry if beta is actually one
to start with which is kind of like
exponential discounting then there's no
problem because in the future she will
just want the same as in the present
so then uh sort of by construction or by
sort of assumption then beta hat equals
beta equals one
but and now if you change this to mine
in the future uh about her
preferences essentially if her if a beta
is smaller than one
then the question arises what's the beta
hat is it like one that's sophisticated
the perfect sophistication case
or is it uh beta which is type beta is
beta hat equals beta that's the perfect
sophistication case
or if beta-hat equals one that's the
full naivete
uh case and then there's sort of cases
in between where like she sort of
she does understand that a beta is like
smaller than one in the future
but doesn't fully understand that and
underestimates uh
overestimates her or beta but at least
only to to some extent
any other questions
okay so now when we sort of look at now
what does a naive student actually do
well so what does the naive student do
at period t equals zero
well from above we sort of know that the
self zero prefers to do the problem set
at t equals one
right so since she's naive she thinks
she's going to follow through with those
plans
so she believed that she will actually
do it at t equals one
so she doesn't do it at t equals zero
now of course what does she actually do
then and
p at pure t equals one we already said
that um she does actually not want to do
the period and t equals one
uh that the p set at uh uh period t
equals one so then hence the
person sort of surprises herself and
actually ends up doing it in period two
right um and so what's sort of the
summary of that and this is sort a more
general
phenomenon if you read sort of the paper
for class today
uh that's sort of much more general um
in that paper and sort of you could do
that
in a much more complicated way um so
essentially there's like um
the belief and period zero she thinks
like well i cannot do it right now i can
delay it
the cost of delaying it will not be that
large because i'm gonna just do it in
period one
but it turns out the cost of delaying is
actually much larger because in period
one she doesn't do it
she'll do it in period two now if you
had more and more period you could sort
of have a whole cascade of like doing it
every day every day you say you're going
to do it tomorrow
but you're never actually going to do it
and so that can lead to actually very
large
costs of procrastination because you can
essentially delay things like infinitely
by every time thinking you're going to
do it in the future and
so that kind of behavior might persist
for a long time
and it's sort of an example as you call
it like naive procrastination
every day you think or every week you
think you're going to do it tomorrow or
next week and so on but you're never
going to actually um do it
and then that can lead to very very
really large welfare costs
because there's like stuff that's
actually not that hard to do but you
just don't do it every day and it gets
more and more costly over time and you
never end up doing it
and it's like way worse to do it in like
50 periods from now
you could have just done it early on if
you had understood that like
uh uh you were not going to do it
anytime soon
any questions on that yeah what's the
interplay
like
[Music]
so they should probably be sophisticated
yes so one big question is like how's
this even possible that we have here
here's a person
who keeps surprising herself every
period and like okay actually i thought
i was going to do it but surprised i'm
actually not going to do it
but i'll you know tomorrow i'll do it um
in a way that's sort of surprising in
the sense of like there are these
behaviors like for example when people
think about when do people
go to bed for example um and people
think you know people systematically
underesti
under invest in sleep um and in some
sense it's an odd sort of
behavior and a sense of like you go to
bed every night you kind of know that
you're going to be tired tomorrow yet
every day you sort of have this belief
that like tomorrow you'll be just fine
and from tomorrow like things will not
change so there's some behaviors where
people tend to not
learn and we don't quite understand why
that is
um in general sort of like learning
about beta
hat is sort of a kind of like at the
frontier of research right now
people have started estimating beta hats
they have found like people tend to be
fairly naive in various uh situations
but then the question is like how is it
possible that people are still not even
situations where like
you know we're going to the gym it's
like every week you can have the choice
of going to the gym
uh you know you should have learned by
now what your type is in some sense what
your beta is and you should have sort of
then updated your beliefs
accordingly and sort of change your
decisions but somehow people have not
sort of done that and people tend to be
naive in situations but really they have
lots of situations or lots of occasions
to learn
similarly if you think about like
problem sets that you're doing in some
ways you know at the beginning of the
semester kind of like um
what's going to happen in some way you
should know
yet you know people tend to be over
optimistic in various cases i was like
an undergrad advisor for a while and
i was sort of advising students on
course choices every semester were the
same thing i would say like four classes
or grades um
um and so on students would take like
six or seven um and then you know i
would say like well
um you know that tends to net and not
end up very well
students are like no no this semester is
different i'm gonna work
i'm gonna work really hard it's gonna be
all great and then you know like a month
later we would meet and then we would go
down to five classes and be like well
maybe four classes are also fine
no no five classes are great and then at
the end you know we end up with four or
three
so you know in a way um uh there are a
bunch of behaviors that repeat over time
and sometimes you would still think
uh why are people not learning one
explanation why people don't learn is
like in some sense they don't want to
learn in the sense of like
i like to be a person i like to think of
myself a person who is virtuous who is
hard-working who's going to be like
really uh
doing great at classes and so on so i
want to be that person i feel better
about myself by wanting that
and therefore i might not sort of learn
as much as i could even though that's
costly for me to do
we're going to talk a little about this
in terms of like overconfidence and so
on
where essentially people have motivated
beliefs and people want to be
uh the person with beta equals one but
in fact they might not be
okay so now um what is a sophisticated
student do we already sort of
discuss that essentially the person
already knows the person has rational
expectations so the person knows that if
she doesn't do it in period zero
she's not going to do in period one
because the period one self will change
their minds and not follow through with
her plans so she's gonna do it in period
two
now anticipating that her choices
essentially effectively between doing it
right now
versus in period two right that's the
effective choice that she has
and now um um we can now like just make
the choice does she prefer doing it in
period zero versus period two
well uh she prefers doing it in period
zero because period two is like too
costly for her even if that's in the
future
and therefore she does the problem set
at period t equals 0.
okay any questions
okay so what's the summary of that well
the sophisticated
student for a case of investment goods
uh
there that person knows that if she
delays she'll delay even more so like
once you start procrastinating you know
this is going to unravel i'm never going
to actually do it
and anticipating that she's going to say
well i'd rather do it right now because
i know this is going to unravel or it's
going to derail in the future
i'd rather not sort of have to do it
very late late at night and so on and so
forth so let me do it um
right now so that student in that
specific case does better than the naive
student
and for the case of investment goods
sophisticated procrastination does not
cause large welfare costs it's not
possible for a perfectly sophisticated
person
to procrastinate things for a long time
and sort of lead to a very inefficient
or costly outcomes the reason being if
you know that's going to be costly in
the future
if it's really that bad you would rather
do it right now
right and so therefore they cannot be
like there can be some cost of like
delaying you might do it tomorrow and
you might do it a little bit later than
uh
than optimally but it cannot be that you
like procrastinate for a long time
and never do it and therefore get like
really large costs
of that
okay so one um
question that also came up in the online
forum that you also saw in the readings
and we're going to also talk a little
bit about in the problem set
is well is sophistication always good
and it's very intuitive to think that
like
sophistication always helps after all
like knowing
uh things better having correct beliefs
about yourself
that seems to be like the correct thing
so intuitively it feels like that should
only help should only make things better
if i understood my biases better i
should be doing
better now it turns out that's true for
investment goods so for investment goods
these are the goods but you have to do
something in the present but the costs
sorry the benefits are in the future for
that sophistication
is always better or weakly better the
reason being that again like you can
sort of understand your future
misbehavior
and by that understanding your future
misbehavior you can sort of avoid sort
of bad things happening in the future
by doing it right now and earlier so in
that case
um sophistication is always better now
it turns out for all these are good
that's actually not the case so leisure
goods again are the goods like where
like you can enjoy something in the
present
and there may be some costs um delayed
in the future
and so um um let's look at and this is
very close to now the paper um that you
read
um suppose there's a student who has
beta equals one-half and delta equals
one as before
suppose the student can go to uh only
one movie and exactly one of the four
periods there's only one movie ticket
that she can use in period zero one two
and three by the way matthew raymond is
a huge johnny depp fan in case you uh i
haven't noticed
um uh so he uses johnny depp in various
of his his papers and uh
and so on he also had a huge johnny depp
poster in his office
um so um the instantaneous utilities are
such that
uh they're like one three quarters nine
fourth and uh 27 eighth
so they're sort of increasing over time
right so if you uh today's like
essentially one day where it's like the
most fun to watch the movie
perhaps because you can go with your
friends or like whatever like uh
it's a better day to do it maybe a bit
better rested or whatever it is
but sort of delaying would be good now
the problem of course is that the person
is impatient the person might not want
to wait because the person is present
bias might want to watch it earlier
the question now is when does she
actually go um watch that movie
so now um there's a way in which you can
sort of write this down
in a very um simple form which is a a
table of discounted utilities that's a
simple tool for solving these kinds of
problems
um this is supposed to come sequentially
but um it isn't today so something's
already filled out for you so that's
easier for you
so what i have filled out you for you
here is um
uh the instantaneous utility so first
the first row here is essentially just
say
these are sort of the assumptions that
we have you have the instantaneous
utilities you zero you one your t
your three and so on right so there this
is essentially what you see in the first
row
of this table second then i have filled
out for you
sort of the utilities the from the
perspective the period zero period one
and period two
right so from the perspective of t
equals zero the first period t equals
zero equals just the same that's just
one because she puts
weight one on that but then everything
in the future is like discounted by
one-half because the beta is one-half
yes okay and then from
the perspective of t equals one of
course t equals zero is sort of relevant
because hours in the past by definition
we only care about stuff that happens in
the future because we can't change the
past
notice that's also an assumption but
it's a common assumption made in
economics
so there you know three three halves now
is in the present so that gets weight
one
and everything that's in the future gets
like weight one half so you have like
nine eighths and
uh 27 16. um and now for period um
uh two again like period now zero and
one or in the past
uh now she cares about the present uh
period t equals two uh with a weight of
one that's nine fourth
and now um t equals three is in the
future that's discounted by
one half okay and now what i also have
done i've like written down the ranking
of these different periods
like from the perspective of uh from the
sort of just looking at the
instantaneous utilities
threes better than two is better than
one is better than zero
from the perspective of t equals zero
you prefer three over two over zero over
one
from t equals one you plus three over
one over two and from perspective of t
equals two you prefer two over three
does this all make sense what i've
written down here
i'll let you look at this for a second
okay so what does the naive person do
with beta hat equals one
yes
oh wait hold on we can do this step by
step
okay so you start zero and then for the
perspective of p equals zero
you would most prefer to do something at
time
three yes um so i guess
that means that you don't do it in
period one and then you move on to
t equals one and then again you want to
do it in period three so you don't hear
the period one either
and then you end up at t equals two and
then you'd rather do it in
period two then period three so you do
it in period two yes
correct so let me uh do that in uh slow
motion
so um in period t she makes some plans
you wrote down what is her preferred
plan in period uh t equals zero
we have our ranking at the very right uh
and the rate and the last column on the
right
uh she prefers to do it in period three
she thinks that she's going to follow
through with her plans
so she's not gonna do it in period zero
because you know she thinks she prefers
privacy so let's just wait
right so she doesn't go in um actually
she doesn't go in
um in periods t equals zero
and pure t equals one is the same thing
now she essentially
uh says well she prefers three over one
over two it's better to do it in period
three so let's just wait until period
three
uh now of course period two comes once
once period two comes
uh it turns out um uh uh we cooked up
the numbers such that like prefers
a period two over period three so she
surprises herself by actually watching
the movie and period two
okay any questions
okay so now instead what does a
sophisticated student do
so this was the perfectly naive student
uh doing it
watching the movie in period two now if
you're sophisticated what do you do
yes
[Music]
equals one she's not gonna wait until
she's gonna
she would go so like if she were at um
t equals one um she knows that if she
waits then she would go
at two instead of three um
but she likes um one
so like her choices not between like one
and three but
between like one and two so if she were
at
time period one then she would go choose
to go at one
and then um if she's at
time t equals zero her choice is going
to be
between zero and one not zero and three
so that
if she were at time periods it was she
would just end up going again
correct so let me also say that a little
slower again
so if we look at perfectly naive people
we're gonna start from the beginning and
go forwards okay
we have like a naive person has plans
going forward and then we just
look at how does this plan evolve so you
started how does this person decide uh
how does this person decide at period t
equals zero thinking she's going to
follow through
let me go to period one thinking she's
going to follow through then we go to
period two
thinking she's gonna follow through and
that's how we sort of solve the problem
now for the sophisticated person we
would do things differently we
essentially use backward seduction uh
essentially to say
let's start at the very end the reason
that we can use backwards inductions is
because people have rational
expectations
the person knows exactly what she's
going to do she's going to start from
the end and say okay how is this going
to play out what i'm going to do
in the end and sort of anticipating that
perfectly
we're going to then uh self backwards
okay so um
as you just said in period 2 we know
that she's gonna go if she hasn't
because she prefers two over three
that's the last row that we have
she likes two better than three when
once she comes to like period two
now in period t equals one she knows
that she's not gonna wait until period
three so period three is actually not an
option for
her she knows that's not credible she's
not going to follow through so then it's
just a choice between one and two
she prefers one over two so she's gonna
going in period one now then in period
one two because zero now we know
she realized that she won't wait until
two or three two or three are not an
option for her she would actually prefer
both to a two and three but that's not
possible because her future self will
not stick to her choice
so then the choice really just becomes
between zero and one
um uh and she prefers zero over one
now essentially she goes to that movie
and gets like utility of one
but actually she would prefer any of
these other outcomes actually any of her
other self would prefer her to not do
that
but she actually picks um period one
so then that's an example and there's
like several examples of that where
sophistication can hurt
now why is sophisticated sophistication
hurting here what's the
what's the key part and like why is it
worse for the student to be
sophisticated
in some sense if you think about from
the perspective of
t equals zero she would prefer three
over two over zero over one
or overall if you look at the
instantaneous utilities
uh period two is better right so from
the perspective of t equals zero
period two is better than period zero
yet he ends up going and period zero
so as a sophisticated person actually
would be better off if you were naive
she would if you could sort of commit to
something and say i would i would prefer
to go in number
and period two if she could say if i
only could be naive
that would sort of help her to actually
do it in period two of course you can't
sort of choose that
um uh uh uh but here's sort of um uh
she's worse off from being sophisticated
but what's going on here like why is
that happening
uh yes so she almost mistrusts her
future selves and so preempts that by
taking the previous decision
but then also preempting that she would
preempt her future self she would take
the
previous decision again and so that
makes it so that
she does the action at the very start
instead
whereas the naive person almost blunders
through and manages to take the more
uh the action with the highest entire
details
right so in some ways uh the problem is
set up in a way
that in a way um realistic pessimism the
sophisticated person is like realistic
in their pessimism
she knows essentially um uh that in the
future she's not gonna behave
so she would love to wait but what she
needs to do to wait she needs to have a
sufficiently high benefit of waiting
now how high is the benefit of waiting
it depends on what your future self is
going to do
if you only wait like a little bit the
fistic the the person will say if i go
lift
the choices between zero and one it's
not worth waiting i might as well go
right now
so if i can wrongly sort of have the
illusion to myself that i say well
um i'm gonna like not go in one um or
in two for that matter then in some
sense
the benefits of weighting the perceived
benefits of weighting are higher than
they actually are
and in this case it mitigates the uh the
self-control problem or the sort of the
the present bias
the present biased person wants to do it
right now and needs like a sufficiently
high reward of uh for waiting
so if you can sort of perceive if you
can sort of
deceive yourself into thinking that the
words of waiting are high
you're going to actually wait and that's
good for you um in this case
if instead you're realistic about your
future self you know that waiting
is not really helping you very much you
know that essentially if you if you wait
for one period
you're going to go and go in the next
period anyway so then the reward and
that's in part because the numbers are
set up that way
but you know that's now essentially sort
of telling you like well waiting is not
really doing very much because your
future self is also like misbehaving
it sort of uh makes it impossible to
actually wait um
all the way until uh at the very end
therefore it sort of makes the
self-control problem the present bias
worse
because now it's like it's not worth why
even bother just like uh wait a little
bit
because that's really not worth doing um
really what you would need is like
weight all the way uh through
yeah so i think this is related to what
i was trying to ask
before like if you are sophisticated you
have a beta
in your imperial zero you'll know that
on the next period
your beta is not going to be there and
you're going to experience three over
two
because your teaching portion has
changed with time
so why would you prefer to experience
utility one now
you can experience three tasks tomorrow
because you know that your function is
going to change
no but i think it's um in a way
there's a preference over like in
something that's
again an assumption how people behave
people care a lot about the present and
that's sort of like in some sense in a
bunch of experiments and so on people
really want stuff
right now even if they know that they
will prefer
like stuff in like two days from now or
three days from now and so on
you just you you you are uh impatient
right now and that's what the utility
function is like
um and so that you put less weight on
stuff that's in the future
now if you sort of think about your
future preferences you are
there's a question and that's a
philosophical question in some ways how
do you think about the fact that your
future self wants something different
that is to say for example if i want to
exercise a lot
and i also like to sit on the couch and
watch tv a lot
now my current self wants to exercise a
lot in the future
my future self wants to and i know that
uh wants to sit on the couch
now the question is like which and when
you think about welfare and so on which
self should we respect
and one assumption and this is an
assumption that's built in here is to
say
my current self has certain plans for
the future
and those preferences are the
preferences that i'm using to maximize
i know that my future self wants other
things but in some sense
i'm assuming i know that i know better
this is the utility function that counts
is the current one not the future one
and sort of then i i respect that one
and i'm trying to maximize that
uh sort of subject to my future
preferences being different
right but in some sense you're exactly
right if you think about like should we
tax potato chips for example you're
gonna talk about welfare and so on
should we tax potato chips you could say
well on the one hand
i might say i would like to attack tax
potato chips because i know in the
future i'm gonna eat too many potato
chips
that's good for me but there's a future
itself
actually for myself who would love to
eat potato chips that herself would be
really unhappy
now you get very tricky questions of
welfare in a sense of saying like well
who are we to say that the current self
is different or like should get priority
over the future self the future self
will
really being happy so there are
different views on this
some people including matthew raven
including david lipson and so on would
sort of say what counts is the
current self or like a self that chooses
for the future that sort of the virtue
itself and so on we should use that for
welfare
evaluation that's an assumption there's
other people who would argue that no
like there's all sorts of self who want
different things so if you think about
is it good to increase taxes for potato
chips
maybe because like some cells are better
off and some cells are worse off
and how do we ever aggregate across
those different selves so you get very
tricky questions
but here for our purposes what we're
going to do is we're going to say the
current self
is essentially disrespecting future
utility functions and preferences in the
own maximization and the maximization
problem
that is to say i have a utility function
right now and sort of discounting
function
that tells me how i want to aggregate my
future utility
over time that is what i want and then i
have essentially like a sort of like
constraints
which are coming in sort of in the when
i think about sort of like when you
write down your utility maximization
problem
there's an objective function which is
my maximization problem that's the
utility function that i want right now
and then there's like constraints in
your maximization problem which are
you know in the future my preferences
will change so some options might not be
feasible because of these uh preference
reversals and so on
but that's not to say i'm respect i'm
respecting your future preferences to
the extent that i
need to have feasible plans i'm not
respecting them in a sense of like i
know
right now i know better what's good for
myself
did that answer your question okay any
other
sorry what exactly is the question so
does that mean that
so from the perspective of period t
equals two
you evaluate it with nine fourth from
the perspective of period t equal one or
t equals zero
that is in the future so you uh uh
multiply the nine fourths times one half
which is the beta because it's in the
future
um i'm using sort of from that
perspective so in some sense
there's a bit of a question for
philosophically what's better and worse
because they have different perspective
you can take from the perspective of t
equals zero for example this
sophisticated person would much prefer
uh period
two over period zero or one over zero
right
so i just showed you that the um
sophisticated person goes in period zero
and um but in fact the person would
prefer three and two
right so what the outcome of the naive
person would be better for the
sophisticated person from the
perspective of t equals zero
right and so then there's a bit of a
question from the perspective of t
equals two
if you had gone already in the previous
period probably prefer if you hadn't
gone previously but that's a bit silly
in some sense
but you can essentially you can write
down from e for each self what would
each self prefer
and i think as it is in this example
it's like essentially the sophisticate
essentially does worse
for all cells compared to a weekly worse
compared to the naive person
okay but happy to talk after um
okay so i think we have all of that
sophistication can uh
make things worse so now overall um uh
or so let me
so more general the lessons are so the
question is kind of like whether future
misbehavior
raises or lowers the cost of current
misbehavior
so essentially whether future and
current misbehavior are complements or
substitutes
so if future misbehavior raises the cost
of current misbehavior then
sophistication helps in overcoming
short run inpatients that tends to be
true for investment goods
that was the example that i showed you
first if i know i'm going to misbehave
in the future i'm not going to like i'm
going to procrastinate a lot if i don't
do it right now
then sophistication is good because i
can sort of prevent that by just
doing stuff right now so that those are
the investment goods
with immediate costs there's some
exceptions to that but generally that
tends to be true
now if instead future misbehavior lowers
the costs of current misbehavior
because essentially the benefits of
weighting in this case that i showed you
for the movie are just lower now so the
costs of misbehaving now have become
lower
then i say well i might as well do it
right now i might as well eat the cake
right now whatever there's no point in
waiting
so then sophistication hurts in
overcoming short run in patients
and that tends to be the case for uh
leisure good leisure goods
sort of with uh immediate rewards now
yes
um it has to it mostly it's a little
tricky it's like kind of complicated in
some sense it has to do with specific
cases
but the key question is essentially is
like
in the future does sort of
sophistication
or misbehavior raise or lower the cost
of like future misbehavior does it raise
or lower the cost of
current misbehavior and then depending
on whether that's the case
sophistication or an ivt go in different
direction
right but so essentially there's a true
answer to that and then essentially if
you're naive to this it sort of flips
the direction uh depending on the
numbers
but it's it's more complicated to that
it's sort of these sort of
fairly general statements so it's a
little complicated but
you'll see some examples again in
problem sets and so on yes
does anybody model better hack as a
function of course
uh not so much so usually people tend to
so that's an interesting question so
usually people think beta hat or like
any preference parameters are sort of
often independent of like the costs and
choices that you see
so the idea often is like uh you are
born
with a beta and a beta hat and a delta
and so on that fell somehow from the sky
there's some research on like how
environmental factors and so on affect
preferences for example
we'll show you some research on like how
contact with different types of people
affect your social preferences for
example if you are exposed to
[Music]
many poor people and as a rich person in
your life
you might become a nicer person and
things like that i'll show you some
research about that
so there's some research on like how
exposure to environments affects
people's preferences
in the case of time preferences usually
people just think like by assumption
somehow you came with a certain um
discount factor and that's how it is or
beta delta and so on that applies to all
sorts of settings
yeah for me usually it's like if the
activity is really costly then i'll
procrastinate it's all i act like as a
name but if it's like less costly
usually i'll be
more sophisticated so i mean like
right that's an interesting question so
that's not what people have done and
thought about
in a way there's a bit of a question
whether your cost and benefit structure
can explain your behavior for a given
beta hat
but it might also be that like for some
case in some situations you might say
you you want to be virtu for example
what i'm saying earlier it's like why
are people not learning
for some behaviors maybe you actually
don't care if your beta is like
0.7 or whatever it's like fine but where
some people really care about being a
good and virtuous person and therefore
you're and these are maybe important
choices in life
they would say i'm a serious person i do
this well my beta hat you like to think
of for yourself as
your beta hat being a high that's not
what people have done
very much so there's very there's a
little bit of research of like good
specific discounting
like you're discounting for certain
goods might be different than for others
depending on what kinds of goods they
are so some goods are temptation goods
and others to not
even that is not really in the
mainstream of economics
very much let alone sort of saying like
your beta hat
varies by circumstance i think that's a
very nice idea i don't know any research
that has done that
so far okay so now one question you
might ask like well isn't that isn't it
is it is it beneficial to be
sophisticated
uh couldn't we just all be naive and
everybody's better off so in theory
at least in principle it's sort of
unclear whether sophistication is good
as i told you i showed you just an
example in some cases it's good in other
cases it's bad
if you think overall like many important
decisions or choices in life
tend to be a decisions that involve like
one term uh one-time efforts that yield
future benefits these are investment
goods
so in many cases in life you have sort
of investment goods
like finishing papers presentations
reports
uh you know finding good investment
options for retirement
uh quitting bad habits quitting smoking
finding a job and so on and so forth
so lots of choices are essentially
immediate effort or like you know at one
time or several times like putting an
effort right now where you get future
benefits
so a lot of important things in life are
tend to be investment goods
and in that case i guess sophistication
tends to be good so like essentially it
helps you
now in addition sophisticates
take advantage of commitment devices so
i offer you a commitment device that i
was discussing earlier
the sophisticated person will say great
the sophisticated the commitment device
might help me
great i'm going to demand it and might
be better off because of that
i'm going to show you next week
commitment devices don't always work
maybe sometimes they could actually make
things worse
but in principle at least you know you
think you know commitment devices could
improve things and sort of in that sense
being sophisticated
is good so i think overall if i had to
like choose if i'm sophisticated or
naive
i would probably choose to be
sophisticated at least in this case
um whether that's actually true i'm not
so sure
um there's sort of one
somewhat more subtle thing here is to
say like is it sort of
is the issue here really impatience or
time inconsistency
in the sense of like is it just about
people not caring sufficiently much for
the future
or is it about how important is time and
consistency
and as i said some of the behavior that
i'm going to show that i showed you is
like
impatience is not really the key issue
here it's not about like people not
necessarily caring about the future
but rather people switching their
choices and choosing dominated options
in the sense of like
overall dominated if you sort of commit
there's some options that you prefer
that you end up not choosing because you
change your choices over time
and patients cannot create this type of
behavior what i showed you where like
the sophisticated person says
i would like these options but i'm not
choosing them because i know my future
self will change their minds
that is not possible you cannot generate
this behavior coming from just
impatience
like a delta being like 0.5 or whatever
would not generate
you this behavior what you need is time
and consistency you need essentially
preference reversals um
over time um okay so then
in some ways i think perhaps more most
practical for your purposes
in part for the problem set um how do we
solve sort of problems with
quasi-hyperbolic discounting so as i
told you before for the naive person uh
we can start from the
beginning and why why do we start from
the beginning as a naive person what
sort of why does this work
so i sort of showed you already how to
solve it now i'm sort of generalizing
that in some sense why is that a useful
thing to do yeah
yeah so the naive person thinks i'm
going to make plans now for the future
and by assumption the naive person
thinks they're going to follow through
on those plans
so what you can essentially just do is
you can start with like some plants
uh uh see what the person is choosing
thinking they're gonna follow through
you don't have to worry about like
what's gonna happen in the future
because it you can explain perfectly
what the person is doing in the present
by making plans for every for outside by
making a choice for like the future
periods you have to actually worry about
whether the person's going to follow
through
because the person doesn't even think
about that so you say i can make a plan
for the future assuming you're going to
stick through with that or stick to this
and then you can just sort of roll
forward and say okay i start with period
t equals zero
make the plan for that think i'm gonna
follow through surprise maybe period one
i'm gonna
do something different but then i'm
gonna have the same assumption and so on
i can just go from t equals zero going
forward
under the assumption that i'm going to
stick to those plans
right for the sophisticated person that
doesn't sort of work because a
sophisticated
person knows that if i make some plans
for the future those might not be
feasible because the future self will
misbehave and change their plans
i know essentially that some plants are
not feasible
so what i need to do is essentially just
start from the end and see okay
if certain options are available what
i'm going to do and sort of then walk
backwards
to solve it and that's essentially sort
of rational expectations where
essentially you you
perfectly understand your future
behavior and sort of take in account
into account your future choices
you're going to make them current
choices um at the end
what about the exponential person how
does that person solve the problem
correct correct exactly so what we did
in the in the movie choice
if you go through this example in more
detail you'll notice that essentially
if i know that for example suppose i
want to go in period three but i know
i'm going to go in period two if it
comes down to that
then i'm going to remove period three
for my choice set
or for my my options when optimizing in
period one or period zero
anticipating what i'm going to do in the
future right
so what about the the exponential
discounter
yes
yes so there's two options in fact for
the exponential discounter actually
doesn't matter because you know you
follow
with your plants anyway so you could
start from the beginning and just walk
forward in fact what you can do is like
you can start in period zero make a plan
for everything and just follow through
you don't even have to go to like period
one two and three because you know
you're gonna stick to that plan
so you can essentially just do that you
could actually also do backwards
transactions and i'm pretty sure you get
the exact same answer
it doesn't matter the much easier thing
to do of course is to solve the problem
in period zero and then just assuming
you're
um going to follow through so um sorry
they should say readings for tuesday
the class is on tuesday not on monday
please read the paper by
arielia and wortenbroff read the entire
article
begin to discuss applications from
smoking to drinking setting deadlines
and so on
and apply these models in real world
settings thank you very much